damn bush and Dallas took an emotional
toll on first responders as well and
also on the medical team that treated
the wounded so we go back to Gail at
Dallas Police Headquarters Gail yes
Charlie and Norah we are here I just
have to say something about what you
were saying about the chief everybody
here is describing him as the epitome of
leadership that this man is a rock star
he has his own personal story but he is
clearly devoted to the city and he is
very loved and respected here but as you
mentioned Parkland Hospital is where
seven wounded police officers were taken
doctors Alexander Eastman and Brian
Williams they're both trauma surgeons
there who helped save lives dr. Eastman
as it turns out is also a lieutenant in
the Dallas Police Department good
morning to you both reporting you Brian
I wanted to start with you because when
you first came Alex of course you have
been here before but this was the first
time that you've seen this memorial and
you had a moment what were you thinking
when you arrived inside
I was thinking why
did this happen
and then I start replanned
Thursday night
this shouldn't be here and I so felt you
yesterday at the news at the press
conference when we're all watching you I
know you did to Alan because you said
for you you've been here before you're a
Dalit you're a police officer as well
but yet you're also straddling both
worlds as a police officer and as a
doctor tell us about that
you know Gail I think when you have
something like this happens well
something like this happens in your city
and at the end of the day you're charged
with both of us have spent the better
part of the last two decades of our
lives training and preparing and taking
care of everyone who comes to our doors
no matter what race color creed doesn't
matter and certainly when you work at a
place like parkland
we really do what we do there would not
respect you
doesn't matter we take care of everyone
like this is truly a horrific
and I think usually the operating room
for us you know again and part of what
we do here and when you it's been one of
the reasons why we wanted to come talk
to you this morning is that we really
feel like we have something to
contribute to the conversation and
there's been a lot of talk about race
and there's been a lot of talk about how
different we are
police civilian black/white
you know I think bride and I are a great
example we could not be
any closer friends brothers copies and
so when you step to the operating room
table
there's no and you look down into
someone who's hurt and injured we all
believe the same there's no difference
we're all people on the inside and I
think that's really an important message
to get out that we've got to stop this
and I continue this cycle of violence
and gun violence and protesters versus
police at the end of the day those
people all look the same on the inside
and Brian many people were touched with
you yesterday because you said that this
is personal and it's complicated for you
what is happening in your city today
tell us about that
for something to apologize for losing my
composure no no you shouldn't no
apologize for that I think it sends such
a strong and powerful message about how
many people are feeling don't apologize
for your feelings go ahead it's it's
personal for me
because I understand how black men feel
with their encounters with police
officers but also many police officers
were my friends and colleagues so I'm
straddling both the worlds
respects the police officers i was
thinkning the job they do every day they
go out with their lives on the lines for
us
they're certainly but what works
underpaid and unrecognized and I
certainly think that that should be
addressed but I also do not want the
fact that black men are dying in the
hands of
ignored overlooked and dismissed this is
not blaming anyone this is not choosing
sides this is about just acknowledging
that it is happening and it does exist
we need to talk about this to make some
kind of change and then the two of you
are longtime friends I heard you say
yesterday that you go on vacations
together that your wives are friends but
yet even the two of you are having
difficult conversations or conversations
that you've never had before
I think Gayle when you come from a
different perspective it's it helps us
that we come to that with a strong base
and foundation that we love each other
we would do anything for each other and
and that's not hyperbole at all and we
have done things for each other so we
come at the conversation from that base
and so to begin there gives us a
starting point and that's why I hope
that across America people will realize
that
there's a lot more that we have in
common than we don't and it's really
important I think as we move forward
with this conversation and what do you
hope Ryan that we've all get out of this
previous discussions between Guthrie
salon I regarding law enforcement
incidents they main main in a pretty
superficial level there's a lot of
joking backing back and forth but
certainly now if you become much more
serious okay thank you very much for
joining us this morning both of you
Thank You Nora
Charlie back to you in the studio dr.
Brian Williams sums up the nation's
dilemma and I assume that that's the
dilemma that prison Obama will speak to
today and former President Bush as well
yeah you know they were there I mean dr.
Williams was in charge of the operating
room when they brought in those police
officers and I think the reason that he
choked up there with Gale was because as
he talked about yesterday he was unable
to save many of their lives they were
too too badly when wounded they were
there on the front lines but he's also
speaking beyond the role of the surgeon
because as he said he's straddling that
role and he said to yesterday that as a
surgeon and as a black man when he sees
a police officer he tries to pick up
their tab at lunch buys them a piece of
ice cream and I think that's a message
that all of us can remember and
hopefully emulate in the friendship
between the two of them yeah very nice
they said Thank You Gail